et bien sûr promis
c'était une fille très géniale
regarde moi guardian
moi ce que je vois zelimir pompe 6 et
murray
c'est le destin
tu sais pourquoi on dit un pompier est
pas une pompière 6 min non c'est parce
que les filles n'ont pas le droit de
devenir pompier
c'est contre le règlement les filles
peuvent pas être pompier mais bien sûr
bonjour euh tu veux dire bonjour il ya
quelqu'un
[Musique]
ma part
tu es un des volontaires
est-ce qu'on se connaît
laisse moi te présenter ton équipe le
cerveau de la bande un grand spécialiste
de la chimie
maintenant d'accord tina ton chauffeur
de taxi le plus rapide de manhattan
t'es qui toi au moins je suis jo c'est
ça jo je suis pompier ce tuto le premier
on se calme joker bien méritée
pression de l'eau
ça ce spécial le pyromane de broadway à
incendier un nouveau théâtre la ville
entière est en danger
tenez vous prêts
on me bats
j'ai pensé à ma fille tu doives à peu
près le même âge il voulait être pompier
aussi
alors pourquoi vous lui apprenez pas
comme à moi parce que c'est ma fille
je l'aimais je suis déjà un qui pourrait
à chaque seconde
spectacle connaît
peut-être que c'est un signe qu'il est
temps de poursuivre vos propres rêves
jamais abandonner les biens